should you start a for-profit or
non-profit company
if you really want to help people if you
really want to have a big
impact and reach a ton of people for the
better
then in my opinion the best way to do it
is to have a for-profit company that
gives
back to the community i got a great
question from a reader greg
who he wants to start up a business he
wants to help
nursing homes and artists and he wants
to start a business around that that can
give back and he's not sure if it should
be a for-profit
or non-profit business here's the thing
okay if you
are just doing a non-profit if it's just
you if you're trying to raise money
through donations
you're always going to be limited if you
are out just volunteering for a company
you can have an
impact and that might be a really
meaningful contribution that you are
giving your time to something
but if you really want to have a big
impact if you want to help more than a
few people
then the best way to do it is to build a
highly profitable business
and invest the money that you make back
into
the causes that you support here's an
example of a friend of mine
he runs a a design shop and he'll help
create great products for companies and
one of the challenges he had when he was
starting up was
i love working with with these
non-profits with these charities because
i love that they're all about i love
their cause
but if i do that i'm not making money
right i either do it at a loss i do it
for free i do it at cost i'm not making
money
so his opportunity here is either do i
go and
basically just work with these
non-profits
and give them my services and i love
doing that work and this may be
personally fulfilling
but he's always going to be limited by
how much time he has
he's never going to be able to grow and
scale and build a team
because he's not making money
whereas if he were to go out and build a
design shop that is for profit that is
doing work
for companies who pay him who pay him
what he's worth because he has
mad skills and then donate 10
of his time 20 of his time whatever it
is back
to helping those causes then in the
longer run he'll have
much more impact because it's not just
going to be
him and his time it can be his team
where if you're just volunteering if
you're just donating
your time or you're you're believing a
cause and you're just investing your
time into something
you're building a non-profit then it's
going to be so
limited it could be 100 of your time but
it's harder to build up
a team around you whereas if you're a
for-profit company
you're making lots of money you bring on
a team say you're a 10-person company
a 20 person company if everybody's
giving 20
of their time to this cause with tons of
different skill sets
you're gonna have a much greater impact
so that's my challenge to you how much
of an impact you want to have
and really the decision you have to make
is
the first option you can get personally
involved and it will be very
personally fulfilling for you because
it's your time but you're not going to
make a lot of money
doing it if anything but you're giving
everything you got to it
whereas the other one you're not giving
as much time to it
but you're having a bigger impact
because you have a business
that can support the causes that you
belong to i'm a big believer that
entrepreneurs need to give back to their
community
if it's through sponsorships if it's
through you know dollars if it's through
time if it's through mentoring whatever
it is
something that you proudly believe in
make that part of your business
bring that into what you do as a company
but then it's still a for-profit
business and the bigger that i can grow
my business
the bigger that you can grow your
business the greater
positive impact you can have in your
community and afford
to give more dollars and resources and
time of yourself
and your team to support the causes that
you believe in
so if i was ever given the option i
would always pick
go for profit have a huge impact change
the world
and believe for those of you watching
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below it always makes me want to do
more for you and let me know what you
think leave a comment underneath you
like this video
stop just being a stalker leave a
comment say something i love to hear
from you and if you have a question
leave it below i'll make a video
response thank you so much i'll see you
soon